why does socialism keep arising over and
over again one way of answering that
question is it is the easiest way to
become a leader of men why because in
any functional Society socialism is like
the lowest skill way to put yourself at
the head of a mom
Mark Andreessen said that you're the
person with the highest output per
minute of new ideas of anybody I've ever
met in my life that seem accurate
well I think he said new good ideas new
ideas alone but I think he qualified
with good or useful or something like
that but yeah that's a high compliment
from Mark who's a who's a friend and
colleague going way back
um
what's going on there is there some
formal system that you're following are
you space repetitioning or semantic
networks or something exotic how are you
resurfacing all of these ideas and
holding on to them
uh you know it's good I probably should
do some formal system
um and that might be like a force
multiplier or something I'm definitely
interested in uh you know like quantum
dot country has a good implementation of
so-called mnemonic media
um and whatnot uh
I think what it is is that I have a
single a few
let's call it a single threaded world
view right I have a certain vision of
the future and then everything that I
see
I sort of attach to that in some way and
so oh that's a little subroutine of this
piece and this little subroutine of that
piece so if you've got like a
clothesline a world view you can attach
pieces to it and um and that helps you
remember things and then you know if you
have that world view you're like okay
this is going to be a piece of the
future because I have this projection of
this macro concept here's a micro
concept for example let's say you
believe the future is the apocalypse but
with internet
okay which is kind of what I think a big
piece of the future is all right
um and so the apocalypse with internet
your pro Soylent your pro coinbase your
pro cryptocurrency your pro remote work
your pro uh like digital Nomads you have
this vision of the future you're bearish
on Fortune 500 you're bearish on suits
and ties you're bearish on
um Legacy commercial office space your
bearish on the west and you're bullish
on Asia and so on and so forth right
like just that thing alone kind of gives
you a certain set of Plus on these minus
on these that that right there kind of
summarizes big pieces of world view
right and then of course there's
exceptions to that because I'm I'm
bullish on Estonia even though that's
part of the West you know bullish on you
know Miami even though that's part of
the West so you have second order
corrections to those first sort of
things and I'm bearish on aspects of
China even though that's part of the
East and so on right so
um so that's kind kind of what I do and
you know it's very hard actually to do
more than one thing
you can do one big thing and you can
attach lots of subroutines to that but
if you're doing more than one thing then
you have to decide for every single
moment of the day am I spending it on a
or b which is why like elon's life must
be very difficult because he has to
constantly choose between SpaceX and
Tesla because they're not really the
same thing and so
when push comes to shove Tesla probably
gets second you know uh
if he must be at some meeting for one of
the two he'll probably be at the SpaceX
medium because getting to Mars is more
important and it's on a shorter time
scale than the cars anyway go ahead
I heard while uh Bezos was at Amazon
that he had a single unifying principle
for that all decisions got filtered
through as well and it's does this make
the customer experience better
everything goes through that I'd heard
that elon's was uh does this get us
closer to Mars but there's some things
that he does with Tesla that I guess I
don't know maybe autonomous driving is
going to give us some kind of insight
around the way that lies it's hard you
already see you already see the tension
right yeah those are those are important
missions it's amazing that he's gotten
as far as he has but they really are two
different kinds of things that you know
that that some would pull away from each
other you know that you can't really
think of them as part of the same
company you know whereas I love the idea
of you hanging off of a clothes rail all
of these individual elements you've got
this single thread which is connecting
stuff and I suppose that that must help
to make uh the things that you keep a
hold of and the things that you don't
relatively lean because you say look
yeah this is the thing that I'm focused
on am I concerned with something does
this map onto it does is hang on to it
is there a peg for this to fit on no
okay well it it's fun maybe or
entertaining but broadly irrelevant
that's right and I think it's kind of
like if if you talk to anybody who's
like uh who's teaching people
programming or something like that
they'll tell you that it's hard to just
learn to code you have to learn to code
to do something right for example it
could be as simple as
I've got my sales data and I want to
create some charts and graphs right or
um I want to rename 100 music files
something really simple like that then
you have a reason to learn to code and
it's the difference between
I don't know learning French in school
where you're memorizing lows and laws
and actually trying to order something
at a restaurant where you're trying to
put a sentence together for a purpose
with a sort of unforgiving you know
French Waiter on the other side okay who
will sneer at you and be like they speak
English please you know right and uh you
know so so that's like the the
difference between coding something
where the market is demanding it versus
just doing some little script so in the
same way
when you're learning with intent to
reuse
um it does filter down the world and you
kind of can snap to grid these things
and that's why I think the
purpose-driven life is good you have a
purpose and you think a lot about what
that purpose is
and then that's your vector and then the
things you know for example let's say
you know your purposes get as jacked as
possible that's like a pretty good
short-term goal that was actually my
goal in my 20s and I was actually as
jacked as possible to be given a South
Asian physionomy okay I know that you're
currently you know that's a that's a
probably a big thing for you and for the
Watchers or what have you right and I'm
gradually getting you know back back to
Jack in my slow way or whatever I got
became a real fat so during the start
because you you basically have two
babies right you know you have your body
and then you have the startup and this
is similar to the tension I was talking
about before because let's say you have
150 people reporting to you right
then the thing is like you feel guilty
when you're like oh I should go work out
because guess what that means this deal
that affects 150 people they don't care
at least your thoughts going through
your head they don't care if you work
out or not because like what they care
about is that deal comes through and you
can you know like have a deal that
affects all of their lives and so as CEO
or as a senior executive your personal
life and your health gets compacted back
if you have a sense of responsibility
it's like serving two masters now
over time what I was able to articulate
is perhaps an obvious thing which is you
have to actually tell your team that you
know everybody needs to work out
including yourself and that you'll
actually bucket time for that you'll
actually put that on the calendar
because there's a sustainability aspect
if you're powering yourself with you
know like
Donuts or cookies it'll get you through
that sugar for like the day but you're
it's like Health debt it's like
technical debt that will cause you to
crash in the medium to long run you
won't be as productive as if you're
lifting and running and whatever right
but that's a good example of the the
serving two masters thing where you need
to kind of you know you you basically
are reducing one hour a day and you're
blocking it off but you're explaining to
people why and it's an investment
towards the future and of course if you
really need to break glass in case of
emergency and you really need to skip
the workout day okay fine but it's like
a significant cost to both you and
everybody else right as well as it is to
them so
anyway why was I saying that so the
purpose-driven life would mean now when
you're kind of scrolling through the
randomness of the internet you're like
oh that's some like Bro Science thing
let me let me file that away for later
right and it's actually like a useful
Thing versus
um you might just you know scroll past
that if you didn't have a purpose to map
it to go ahead there's an Aristotle
quote where he says if a man knows not
where he sails no wind is favorable
exactly that's right without a vector I
mean in fact actually this is a huge
part of
web 2 is it's entropic and that's a big
part of what this book is about you mean
by entropic so
um entropic in the sense of entropy like
for example if you're not interested in
heat and work heat is like all the
particles are moving in different
directions and work is like force along
a distance yeah and
so the the difference is if you go and
look at Hacker News or Reddit or Twitter
or Facebook any of these things there's
something in common among all those
sites if you just refresh them that
you'll see now that you probably won't
be able to unsee after I say it which is
it's 30 random things
it's literally 30 random links and it is
optimized for novelty but what that
means is every day you're like let me
start off okay I'll get a little bit of
this and a little bit of that and a
little bit of this and what happens is
in this High dimensional space you're
just being pulled in a bunch of
different directions and not really
making progress progress would be I do
some math today and I do some more math
in the same area tomorrow and some more
at so a little bit of compounding
progress along a direction Vector each
day adds up to something but these
entropic sites add up to nothing right
or maybe you you're kind of aware of
what the community is thinking I'm not
saying they're at zero value there's
some value to Serendipity don't get me
wrong okay but I think we are
over consuming novelty
and under consuming purpose and that
gets us into the concept of the
information diet just like the diet
right you know you you diet with a
purpose you eat these things and not
those things because you have a you know
a classifier function you're putting on
the food this good this bad right and
you know might be low carb it might be
you know one meal a day you only eat
within this window when and not
otherwise right
um
so it could be one meal a day it could
be
um
I don't know you have some metabolic
restriction you can't have like some
some particular compound right you have
some filter that you're putting on food
and so you know this good this bad and
that same kind of thing a filter that
you're putting on information this good
this bad is like a very valuable thing
where you're doing it not it's the
opposite of what censorship it's
self-control right it's directedness you
know it is um it's directed consumption
of information no external parties
imposing it on you you are blocking out
this cookie like junk information and
then you're actually going for the good
stuff and what's the good stuff I argue
it is that stuff that
is helping you boost measurable
variables right boosting your you know
truth health wealth right it's your
knowledge it is your you know like your
physical fitness or something like that
um or it's your bank account balance or
some combination thereof right those are
things which are the dashboard variables
you should be like trying to level up
each day for you and your family and so
on and so forth and then you're really
making progress versus a lot of the
other stuff is kind of like cookies it's
like drugs it's it's something where you
click it and you're enraged about
something in some distant part of the
world that you have no control over
and uh you're not like leveling up these
like critical variables the problem that
you have with information diets is a lot
of the time it's KFC masquerading as an
apple you can't tell healthy information
from unhealthy information
what I don't know I mean the way that
orification and food diets have now been
designed is
almost as obfuscated as you could say
the internet is but maybe it's a little
bit more messy like there's no
ingredients right on the back of an
article that you've read or something in
the same way that a little bit of
understanding of what goes into food
could tell you about that so how do
people become more Discerning there it's
a great question so I'd say three things
about that first is you know there's a
one-liner which is the most nutritious
food is the stuff that doesn't have
nutrition facts on it
right because it's the lettuce it's the
tomatoes you know it's the stuff like
that right it has to be a little bit of
a chemistry experiment to have the
nutrition facts on it someone's putting
it into a par bomb calorimeter and
getting those numbers out of it right
that's just kind of an amusing
observation right
um the uh the second thing is that
um I think there's two ways of dealing
with that information content thing
uh the first is maybe someone can
develop a chrome plug-in which basically
pre-reads the stuff for you and will
flag it for example you know all the
words on the page that are meant to
enrage you
can actually be flagged
okay and that's called you know for
example this is console called Russell
conjugation and it's like it's actually
by Bertrand Russell and the idea is uh I
sweat you perspire but She Glows
okay it's the same concept can be
communicated with a totally different
tone on it depending on whether you want
to you know give a positive spin on it
or a negative spin right like uh you
know you are righteously angry
um he is spluttering with rage right and
you know so the same concept can be
Russell conjugated in different ways and
when machine learning you can detect
that so one thing you could imagine is a
chrome plug-in that would just sort of
be like a buddy alongside that would
sort of pre because the thing is you
might think you're a super rational
person but when that hits your eye uh
you're you're gonna see it whereas if
it's highlighted in red you're like oh
okay yeah you're right yeah I didn't
even realize that was down to regulates
my response against this particular term
a little bit more yeah exactly and if
you open up a page which is covered in
red you think I probably need to take
this with a little bit of a pinch of
salt exactly and in fact that's what
they've added to it also in a different
sense is they've added a pinch of salt a
pinch of sugar to the page Street news
is boring so instead they sugar it up
they salt it up with all of these things
you know so you're saying that the
limbic hijack of semantic overload
online is basically the same as
carefully designed shoes think about a
failing restaurant right a failing
restaurant will start throwing all kinds
of sugar and other stuff into its food
why because
um it does like people like it it's a
short-term optimization you know and you
know people saw fruit yogurt wow that's
selling right it's like you know
Coca-Cola where they put cocaine in the
in the cola and like now today we're
like wow that's so bad like at some
point in the future when everybody has
continuous glucose monitors and you can
actually see your blood sugar jangle and
so on we will see this time period when
people had sugar for breakfast sugar for
dessert when kids were eating sugar when
sugar was in everything as similar to
like that time when drugs were laced and
everything okay I can't believe people
used to put that in their bodies yeah
exactly like and that's why people were
so fat and that's why diabetes was such
an epidemic and why people are up 30
pounds like it's actually like this it's
very difficult to escape it's like
secondhand smoke sugar is basically in
almost everything right you have to
really try to not eat that you know and
um
and it probably starts messing up your
uh your your gut microbiome and other
kinds of things this is why have you
seen the GIF on the Obesity epidemic
have you ever seen the gif I'm not sure
you should yeah screen share and we can
uh yeah I'll just I'll just paste this
in just for your you know this is
actually 10 years ago and people have
gotten even fatter since then okay but
take a look at this if you put that on
your
thing Dean make this pop up when you uh
when you do the edit please thank you so
this is
just the us but it's Global you can see
that you see when the thing about
so for the people that are just
listening it's a map of all of the
states in the US and it's beginning in
about 1985 beginning with no data and
then it gradually gets darker and darker
all of the colors over time and it is
what's that at the bottom is that BMI
it's obesity yeah it's it's basically
like exactly it's like a percent of
people who are above oh no obese BMI
right okay yeah and just over time
you're getting to what's that at the top
is that over 30 in some places now yeah
yeah predominantly well everywhere this
is 10 years everywhere it's just gotten
worse since then yeah right and the
thing is and this is important even
though it's BMI BMI is a function of
height and weight which are both
so-called ratio scale variables and
those are good variables the reason is
six feet is six feet in 1980 and in 2022
right
um 150 pounds is 150 pounds in 1980 and
in 2022. so so ratio scale variables are
the highest quality of data because they
can be compared across time and space by
contrast dollars are not because that
you have to inflation adjust them and so
on and so forth right and other kinds of
metrics like SAT scores and stuff are
are not because you know scales change
and what sort of less comparable across
time and space so ratios give scale
variables like this or functions of
racist scale variables are something
where we can really truly say people
have gotten fatter over time
significantly fatter and is it partly
due to uh you know like a microbiome
maybe uh because
like ulcers were thought to be
completely you know from stress and so
on in like the 70s and then
um people found a guy won a Nobel Prize
for it actually showing that it was
partly due to microbe it could literally
be something it's partly due to microbes
but it's probably some kind of
combinatorial thing where it's like both
the diet and the sedentriness yeah and
the microbe and so and so forth anyway
since 1980 men have lost an average of
one percent of the testosterone
testosterone yeah yeah I got a thing
sent through from Rob Henderson the
other day eight out of ten Young
Americans are ineligible to enlist in
the US military primarily due to obesity
factors but medical issues and criminal
records also contribute
yes so the thing about this is is it the
plastic is it the you know being fat is
it being sedentary
it's some is it you know I don't know is
it like basically messages that you're
getting on social media is it some
combination of all these
um it could also be just a single Factor
like lead that we don't even know like
the Plastics right like you know the the
Romans reposing themselves and didn't
even know you know and um I mean
certainly we have a lot more
um
compounds that are out there that were
you know like exposure to plastic is way
higher than it was 100 years ago
um and we don't know what we need
actually are better metrics and so with
better metrics like the equivalent of a
CGM you take this out of guesswork and
you turn it into something that
approaches
um empiricism right so what you want is
a stream of data coming out of you that
um and this is another one of my big
topics is
we know what's going on in Budapest or
Bangalore but we don't know what's going
on in our own body right you hold up
your phone it's like Bing here's this
alert on the other side of the world you
know you want alerts on your blood sugar
you want alerts on all this other stuff
that's what you can those most important
metrics right and this is actually
another concept I have which is kind of
related to this you know it's going to I
think replace the daily newspaper
yes because I've read it and I can't
remember what you said it was
I can't remember the personal dashboard
yes okay why do I say this is actually
really important it pulls together some
of these Concepts
the personal dashboard is actually
something if you're a tech executive
this is actually the first thing you
look at each day it's not totally
personalized it's partly but it's like
here's our Revenue here's it here's the
GitHub tickets that are closed and what
you do as like CEO or an executive at a
tech company is it's like you're
steering an airplane but you're putting
different dials you're responsible for
figuring out what those dials are and
pulling them into the cockpit right it's
just companies like looker for example
that just provide these sort of
dashboard Services why is this extremely
important you are in control of those
dashboards right so the first thing you
see is co each day for example is what
was our Revenue yesterday was our
Revenue over the last 30 days what's our
expenditure who's doing what et cetera
et cetera and you don't necessarily need
to be like immediately reactive on every
single aspect of that but you see these
metrics and you're looking for whether
something is out of spec or whether it's
going well and then you kind of
intervene on those parts of the company
which are functional or non-functional
right and so the crucial thing here is
that is news you can use
right that the locus of control is you
you can do something about it now you
imagine that where it's not just your
corporate dashboard but it's your
personal dashboard for your own
um Fitness and so on and so forth your
diet your sleep like your Fitbit style
thing and then maybe like a family
dashboard and you have like checklists
like you know uh the the pet needs X and
the kids need you know why they need
like vaccines or whatever it is right
um and
if I don't know if your audience is like
super anti-vaxx or whatever you know
okay all right so the point is you know
people need shots they need they need uh
you know pets need food or whatever it
is
all of those things are just in like
your personal dashboard and you're
tracking these things you know and you
have uh maybe it's your bank account
balance Etc this is more useful to you
than daily checking Twitter daily
checking Facebook you know Fitbit is
actually a much better app in many ways
than those you know and so you can
imagine some combination of like Fitbit
and Brilliant and your you know your
bank account and so on that's like
brilliant.org I love that site that's
like truth that's like what you know
right Fitbit is your health truth that's
health and then your bank account thing
or your crypto is your is your wealth
right so that's like you know the right
app to check each day in my view and
then mediated by that you can take other
actions and then everything else is
actually seen as junk food you know and
so rather than a social app it's like a
personal app this kind of thing which I
mean nothing I'm describing doesn't
exist you know like or I say everything
I'm describing exists right but
the concept of it replacing the news is
really important because
the news is like you know think about
you know opening your daily newspaper
first thing in the morning people have
built that habit I'm gonna you know
drink some coffee and read the newspaper
first thing that's not what you should
read first thing random events on the
other side of the world are not what you
should care about first thing that
precious precious space of like what you
load into your brain the first thing you
know frankly perhaps your first few
hours when you get up should be offline
you know they should be like pen and
paper writing things out or write it up
the night before you should go and work
out first all that type of stuff some
offline time is good so you don't just
immediately Just Jack into the internet
right when you're getting up you have
some focused time but when you do then
it should be dashboard in my view and
you can set that up yourself by the way
you can just set up your own home page
you can set up your own thing you can
set up your own dashboard the apps exist
de-prioritize other people pinging you
so now you have at least a few hours
each day where you're moving the ball
forward in your own self-determined
Direction okay let me pause there
you said one of the things to look at
would be that the foods which have the
fewest number of ingredients on the back
of the ones that are the healthiest are
the ones that have been kind of molested
the least then you need to be looking at
the sort of inflammatory language which
get which gets used on the internet
perhaps it could be a Google Chrome
plug-in for this longer term what else
are you doing to ensure that your
information diet is a no as lean or as
healthy or as natural as possible
because the bottom line is that right
now people want to know about the world
around them whether that's a cognitive
bias whether it's completely useless or
not people want to find out what's going
on the dashboard is great but you're
going to have to step out into the
child's chaotic world at some point so
what I what I do I certainly now here's
the thing I definitely do read a ton of
stuff right but
what I try to do is I try to get all the
important stuff out of the way
first thing in the morning and one is
not always successful in this right but
you do your workout you do your what's
the tip of the morning take us through
your typical morning
a typical morning
um
well I'll give the ideal warning okay
not the typical morning right I still
got the ideal okay because one always
falls short as being a human but at
least you have an ideal to strive for
right
so the ideal warning is uh you wake up
you just groggly go to the treadmill and
you just start jogging okay and you have
your eye the tiger or whatever it is
over there and actually you know the the
atomic habit style cue right of just all
right this is what I'm supposed to do at
this time it actually does help on the
margins right you've got your you know
shorts and your like socks and shoes all
there next to treadmill so you just walk
up to it and start going and why is it
good to actually have it like at your
house if you I mean it's not that
expensive in the grand scheme of things
you know if you have the space for it
um it's good to have it there because
you never have to wait in line you don't
have an excuse it's right there you can
do it anytime and if you're really tired
then you just walk in the morning or
whatever but you just do that right okay
having done that you have now
won a victory over yourself at the very
first thing then lift if you can do that
if you have a little home gym or
whatever
um now one hour into the day like you're
actually on top of things right do your
morning ablutions blah blah blah you
know and
now
um you know like go and uh like if you
have offline stuff you've got printouts
just go and work on that like I write a
lot of stuff longhand
um and why do I do it longhand it's
because
um oh I'm in second uh
the reason I do a lot of stuff long hand
is because
it forces Focus
right and it's just like zero interrupt
you know you write it out and you can
scribble and you can move things around
and so on I take those pieces of paper
if it's like a draft of a book chapter
or something like that I'll take
yesterday's print out write up long hand
type it in type it oh something else is
actually quite Handy by the way uh
there's certain cookie jars okay
um you know these timer cookie jars uh
yeah I've seen them from mobile phones
before yeah exactly so you can use them
for mobile phones you can also do
something where you like uh drill a hole
in the back and
um so you can put your router in there
or or the plug to your router okay so
that you can basically just okay yeah
why do this right so the reason you do
this is you just kind of have all your
phones in there
you also have the plug to your router
there and just lock it up and you set
the timer for like three or four hours
okay so say you get up at like seven or
eight you work out till nine you are now
offline until like 1pm
and you have just done deep work for
like four hours straight no one in the
world can bother you no one can get in
touch with you no one can tweet at you
you are just offline to the entire world
okay and uh that's good because if you
if you were able to do that and just
push forward with like your priorities
you know now what this means by the way
is you actually need a good printer you
need like you know some like a desk it's
not super expensive or anything but
you're printing actually more than you
might otherwise or you need offline apps
or something like that right like um
which a lot of things work offline you
know
um pages.app or emacs you know emac is
like a terminal based app those things
work offline so you do all this stuff
offline your pen and paper or offline
and then like four hours and then you
connect and you synchronize you push all
your update stuff now you're on the
attack right now you're responding to
emails and you know sending things out
you're looking at your signal you're
looking at your WhatsApp your blam blah
blah blah blah responding to people
um
looking at Investments you know all the
CEOs who are like hey hey you know I
need some help with something or
whatever get on the phone with them
um
and uh you know then you have just Flex
there's like that's like a few hours and
then you can't play in the full day
right so then you do whatever the rest
of the day maybe it's more work maybe
it's like you know you're tired maybe
maybe you're you know seeing the sun
whatever it is right
um and uh and then like at the evening
again an ideal day again this is not
everything but uh you try to write down
those one to three things you want to
get done the next day and then you you
know knock off and one thing that's also
kind of important and again it's not
done all the time but
um I find it you know people say oh
don't look at a screen before you go to
sleep right
um
but people are also sort of addicted to
having like some sort of information as
they go to sleep or whatever so the way
to square that circle is probably like
audio books
right so something like that where you
have uh you know whether
um it's uh like a
uh you know the smart speakers people
are pro and con on them the con is of
course that they're listening to
everything and whatnot right uh and so
it is security vulnerability the pro is
they don't they're not shining in your
eyes you know so that's one option if
you're willing to take that security
risk
um and you can just say play that audio
audiobook and set a timer for 30 minutes
it'll probably knock you right out
um or you can take your phone and you
can you know have that and just have
that lullaby you right for those people
who have to have who want to wean
themselves off it's like a Nicorette if
if people are used to like surfing their
way to sleep at least audible your way
to sleep and you'll find it's way better
right and without the light
it'll it'll put you to sleep you know
and that's like a pretty good day that's
you got your workout you got your your
focused energy on the thing that's most
important
you didn't schedule the whole day you
have time to react you have time
obviously you know if you have family or
things like that if you want to see that
thing that I call outside you know
there's the sun I hear people sometimes
see it okay you can go and do that you
know so it's it's but the main thing
about it is
um
you just spend those first hours on the
most important stuff and drive that
forward before the rest it's kind of
like a a tank where the water is held
back and you know it's going to rush in
but you hold it back to drive forward as
much as you can and then let the water
of the Day rush in okay go ahead a
couple of things that I would add into
that in terms of tools so I just bought
a bike desk so it's a bike with a desk
built in it's purpose-built and this
thing is so comfortable insane
interesting what's a what's a brand or
whatever uh I will be able to send you a
link and it'll be linked in the show
notes below for the people who want to
check it out the one that I got is only
available in the US at the moment but
you'll probably be able to get it
shipped it was about
350 bucks I think so not cheap but not
very expensive okay dude it is
outstanding the backrest means that you
can really set in links up with
Bluetooth on your phone it'll do
pre-done uh programs if you've got a
whoop strap or anything broadcast's
Bluetooth heart rate it'll pick up the
heart rate and give you a full readout
at the end of it and you're just turning
over reading something or answering
emails it's got this really big desk
it's got two cup holders I'm completely
in love with this that sounds cool yeah
send me this send me this what's the
name of it I'll I'll have to send you
afterwards it's some it's one of those
very strange names I'll send you
afterward um the other thing that I
would get is YouTube premium so YouTube
premium allows you to continue to hear
audios no ads no ads is super good yeah
and you can hear the audio of whatever
you're listening to offline so you can
make yourself a little playlist
throughout the day oh this is cool
someone sent me this I should listen to
that later on yeah and I've been
listening to World War II in numbers
which is a British history documentary
series of which there are quite a few
with some of my favorite historians and
it just sounds great and you're hearing
about Hitler went
345 days before he could invade
Stalingrad and you're like this is cool
now and now I'm asleep um so going back
to your um way that you ensure
information diet you're reading a lot
you're consuming a lot outside of your
deep work sessions what are the
principles that you're following to
ensure that you don't get uh how would
you say cognitively fat
it's hard because again what I'm
describing is like the most you know I'm
not trying to be like
oh the CEO gets up at 5am and they
they're on the exercise I mean maybe Tim
Cook is like that 2.0 human being who
just like hits it out of the park every
single day and has that level of
self-discipline where he is like he's
managed to roboticize himself as a human
right
but I I do think that at least setting
an ideal even if one falls short of it
is useful to do you know and um and then
so at least you know what you're
striving for right so
um in terms of information diet I
actually do think uh there are good
aspects of Twitter the weird thing about
Twitter is
you can learn a lot from it and it is an
important water cooler for technology
and other kinds of things it is just
something where there's references where
you know you'll talk to people and
you'll be out of the loop if you're not
on it and so on so there's a utility to
being on Twitter
and then you can follow some interesting
accounts that will teach you about stuff
that you've never heard about right but
and you can also you know when you when
you tweet or whatever you can have
people come and DM you I found lots of
great Investments on Twitter I've met
lots of folks that way so all of that is
to the good
but it's like the it's like the
Serendipity part of the day which is
easy to overdose on if you do it too
much you know so for example just like
you know taking some time off Twitter
which I do every once in a while and
just you know focusing on getting out
the book Logistics and so on was a very
very good thing to do because you're
talking about maybe a week at the time
or a couple of weeks at a time where you
just log out and don't check well
actually I took months off right I took
I took like almost four months off just
to get all the final details on the book
nailed down and get that shipped and you
know the thing about that is uh in a
sense
you know win off Twitter to win on
Twitter
you know so that's to say pretty much
anything that you want to do you cannot
actually win on Twitter itself you have
to win off Twitter and announce on
Twitter
you know now Twitter itself is under
appreciated by people because it is the
public war zone right it is where the
intelligencia Slugs it out it is the
consensus mechanism of the English
speaking internet
okay and it's like where Society now it
is like the true government I don't
think people realize that yet right it's
a parliament
because it's Upstream of government it's
very hard for a government to go against
Twitter
um where Twitter's public opinion is
right and it's a parliament where
there's people from the English-speaking
internet across the entire world
um who are elected by their constituents
right who follow them and uh and so and
of course they can get unfollowed and
blocked or whatever right and uh and
there's no borders in terms of I mean
yes there's National borders and stuff
like that but I mean you're in the UK
I'm in you know like Asia or what have
you
but we're still kind of in at least
adjacent so-called if you're the term
neurosphere no
osphere it's like a cognitive sphere
it's like it's like like our mental
social networks are not so far apart
right uh whereas let's say the Chinese
social network is its own thing its own
Galapagos Islands but not a small thing
it's like a billion person Chinese
internet that is just air gap from the
English internet which is the biggest
thing right and one tweet I actually
just you know digressed in this topic
for a second that I was just talking
about recently the English-speaking
internet and the chinese-speaking
internet are actually like the two most
monitored and surveilled internets in a
sense right the English internet is also
like the public war zone of the world
it's got a few different aspects when
you go outside English and Chinese to
even Spanish it's actually a pretty
large community it's much less monitored
people can speak much more freely
because the platform operators mostly
speak English or Chinese and so
therefore they're not going to basically
like surveil they don't care as much
about thought crime in other languages
isn't that interesting that's
fascinating yeah and so and and it's
funny I tweet about this and a bunch of
people were agreeing with me on that and
they just hadn't put two and two
together on that observation they're
like oh wow you're right if I say the
same thing in Hindi nobody cares
I can tweet this this raging tweet that
I I want to get out there but you can
put out in Hindi exactly nobody cares
nobody will care nobody even thinks of
it as like offensive really that's that
bilingual privilege that everyone's got
something well so it's interesting
because obviously most of the world is
neither English nor Chinese speaking
so now machine translation other things
complicate this in hard to game out ways
the most obvious implication or perhaps
the one that will happen is that it
makes all of those other internets
legible to the English and Chinese uh
social network platform operators and
then the surveillance and the you know
thought police can move in there on the
other hand
it may also mean the rebalization of the
world just like the Israelis revived
Hebrew which is a dead language machine
translation may make it easier for
communities to basically build their own
secret languages or forked off languages
which are at variance with the you know
the main society okay and
um especially if you take the machine
translation models and you add some new
language on them that the main society
doesn't have right so there's different
ways of doing this okay but point being
that
um
I I think this concept is uh is a is a
useful one where you realize the
importance of Twitter
you realize it's it's both it's both
more important than people who say it's
unimportant say and yet you can't win on
Twitter itself you just can't right you
have to do things off Twitter to win on
Twitter now why is it important to win
on Twitter as I said it's basically like
the government of governments uh sort of
like Bitcoin is also a government of
governments right Twitter is the
government of government socially
Bitcoin is government of governments
financially right so like Jack Dorsey is
actually in some ways like the Ender of
this world in the in the beginning of
the next right 200 Bitcoin are the end
of
like basically all post-war institutions
and the beginning of what comes next
speaking of tweets there's a famous
tweet that says Balaji was right might
be the most terrifying phrase in the
English language and you were teaching a
Bitcoin course pretty much before
anybody talked about it you predicted
the exit of Silicon Valley in remote
work pre-covered and then you predicted
most of kovid's implications in January
of 2020 which are probably three of the
biggest trends that we've seen over the
last decade yeah have you got a crystal
ball what's what's going on here well so
uh what do I do so I mean the thing is
it's a funny that statement like
I um I also predict a lot of good things
and I and I invest in and bet on those
things
um but those those everybody's kind of
happy that I was you know right or
whatever uh
for For Better or Worse
um if you're you're seeing Slumdog
Millionaire yes yeah and so you know how
he gets all the answers right not
because he uh like got the answers fed
to him or it was because like his life
experience just managed to make him like
well suited for the moment right
and in some ways like
um you know so I certainly have a mental
model of the future and as I said like
you know my clothesline kind of things
hang on to that right
and uh
you know sometimes you have a productive
mental model that just keeps chugging
out result after results it's kind of
like how uh if you're good at math you
can do a lot of physics you know if once
you're good at math you can be like I
can go into fluid mechanics I can go
into you know electrodynamics that go to
astrophysics I can start generating
useful results right similarly you're
good at computer science and stats you
can go into Airlines you can go into
manufacturing you can go into retail you
can give useful results because
everything has algorithms and it has
databases so computer science useful
into algorithms and stats is useful in
the databases right okay so
you know how how do I predict myself
well first is like the Slumdog
Millionaire thing the world is sort of
just getting more biology like okay uh
what I mean by that is if you were
what's the opposite the opposite is
you're like a 1950s uh like very
conformist person that wants to wake up
nine to five each day and do exactly the
same thing each day that doesn't want
any change and wants to work at the same
job for 30 years that's both
nationalistic and socialistic you know
in a sense right like you're you're a
farmer Soldier slash manufacturing
physical in person kind of person
um you know you don't care that much
about the life of the mind your go team
when it comes to sports
um you know that's like you're kind of
stereotypical like 1950s-ish kind of
thing right
every aspect of that is getting inverted
right so what do you have now you have
um this mobile internet based uh you
have a very fluid day you have high
upside and you have high downside you're
far less certainty in everything and far
less constraint and everything you're in
a time of flux a time of change
um you can code something and go
vertical you can you know get wrecked or
go viral right uh you know and you know
the camera is Shifting to Asia uh like
all of these things superimposed is this
bizarre kind of thing where it's like
okay
I I've just now sort of accepted that
anything that I'm into today will in
five years or ten years become much much
more popular
okay example and this is a small example
but like
um
you know Chris Dixon's also said this is
like whatever quote nerds are into on
the weekend everybody cares about in 10
years right for example Palm pilots in
the late 90s everybody's using iPhones
10 years later right World of Warcraft
well Oculus is pretty big now and I
think VR will eventually get pretty big
Netscape Navigator people are on the
internet in the early you know uh 80s
and the web in the early 90s everybody's
on the web today on social media it was
like Facebook and you know Twitter was
among like the San Francisco Literati
technology and then everybody's on it
right and so you know cryptocurrency is
another version of that
um like for a less high profile version
from 2005 to 2007 Google Maps existed
but the iPhone didn't so what's the kind
of thing I did I was like I had my
laptop and I would
um look up directions on Google Maps and
it'd screenshot the turn by turn and
then I'd have the laptop on the
passenger seat
yeah exactly right so I mean of course
I'd pull over at times or whatever to
look but
you know of course that's a preview of
Google Maps on the iPhone
right so whenever I'm kind of hacking
together something like that now I know
that's an investable opportunity
because that is a problem which is yet
to be solved which you can kind of Jerry
rig into a solution which means that
Downstream it's going to be made into a
much more productive solution yes yes
exactly so what kind of stuff is that
today right so
digital nomadism right
um a full crypto life where you're
basically crypto first on things and
like your bank account is like your
crypto wallet and other bank accounts
are like kind of Downstream of that
um
obviously like so much crypto stuff I I
couldn't even go into all of them but
like from crypto credentials to crypto
social networks to ens names all that
type of stuff will be huge ens has
passed like two million names and
thereabouts
um all the AI stuff especially AI
content creation so AI audio like
synthesis engines will succeed search
engines
like so do you know what I mean by that
no okay so have you heard of Dali yes
okay so the difference between I made
this point on Twitter but like if you
type a query into Google you're
optimized for making a very short often
a single word query and you go to Google
Images right whereas with Dali you type
out this long involved sentence with
lots of Clauses and modifiers and
whatnot you get a better result as a
function of that you're optimizing for
precision on the Dali
as opposed to brevity on Google
yeah and so so essentially basically
you're like people have been trained in
how to search
um and they have to be just completely
synthesis engines have the opposite
instincts from search engines right and
um the you know the way of thinking
about that uh is here I'm going to give
this tweet that you can so
if you take a look at the left image
there
CSS docker
Google images and you see a little whale
with the stuff on it okay if you go to
the right image it's blue whale with
stacks of shipping containers on its
back CG Society art station trending 4K
and you get something very different
right much more
right yeah
okay and now that is the difference
between a search engine and a synthesis
engine like prompt engineering is just
on the total opposite extreme of like a
extremely long detailed
sentence one word just never works
whereas with search one word is really
kind of what you want to reduce it to
right so people have to completely
retrain to think about synthesis engines
because it's not just going to be
synthesis of images it's going to be
synthesis of audio video code
um like longer pieces of text maybe full
video games maybe full apps even right
synthesis engines are going to be
absolutely massive and the right
keywords unlock them it's like open
sesame you know like we're entering like
a World of Magic where if you know lots
of words
okay for example if you look at this one
CG Society art station what the heck is
that oh those are like that's a specific
like 3D Graphics community and by adding
those there
the algorithm knows now to make it look
like the kinds of things that are
generated by that okay and 4K you know
right so knowing obscure bits of art
history that's now an applied subject
okay you can say do it in the style of
Picasso and do it in style of Monet and
do it and style of Rembrandt and you'll
get different looking images as a
function of that the exact same so
here's another one that I had on exactly
that right
um so now of course you know I I
actually I used to be at The Cutting
Edge of ml AI that was like you know 10
years ago I'm not as into the subject as
I was but I'm getting back in
um it's funny like because I was doing
computational genomics for many years
um but now what's going to happen is for
from a Content creation standpoint all
this stuff is now working so synthesis
engines
um you know it's not just obviously me
that's using them as a bunch of other
people that are using a bunch of people
who developed them
that that is that is something where
pretty much anything you can describe
with a few sentences
like Dolly shows that there's like the
limit on that is much higher than we
thought right it breaks through beyond
what we thought was possible right
um natural language is now a programming
language right
um so okay so that's like so I mentioned
what are the piece of the future that
are being lived today right so I
mentioned digital nomadism I mentioned
crypto everything I mentioned
um
synthesis engines I think also the shift
of the camera to Asia is pretty
important
um the level up of India uh that's you
know this is something I tweet about but
one of the most underpriced things in
the world like in the sense of just
nobody's budget for it there's no news
articles about it nobody knows to expect
it is a billion Indians have gotten
online with some of the cheapest you
know internet service in the world and
that means that the plurality if not the
majority of English speakers online will
be Indian by 2030.
okay yeah that's wild that's wild now
just think about the epocal implications
that has for culture for Society
for example like every Creator who's
smart will start trying to appeal to
Indians that's where your following is
coming from right
um that means that Indian culture will
merge with Western culture in ways we
haven't seen before right in many ways
it's actually like
um
it's like emancipation because Indians
can now connect to others directly
rather than going through the whole
nation states Nation safe process yes
right every node this entire gigantic
Atlantis has just sort of like risen up
and now can connect everybody
peer-to-peer and
um you know the full impact of that I
think it's just it's not something that
there's news articles it's not people
preparing you for this people aren't
like people know there's going to be an
election people know uh I don't know
there's gonna be an Olympics or whatever
there's no foreshadowing of this
nobody's even aware this is happening
frankly most people are shocked when I
mention this right
um and that's like that's like just one
huge kind of you know I think Penny
that's gonna drop let me pause there
well you can say I had a Peter Zion on
recently I'm not sure if you're familiar
with him it's spelled like zahan looks
like yeah yeah he's I guess I disagree
with him on a bunch of things but I I
have no personal beef with them I just
to screw them on a bunch of things yeah
but one of the things he said was
demography is Destiny and that's
repurposed from somebody else but
I do think that when you're looking at
India you could also see
um technology as Destiny or
technological adaptation is Destiny 2
and that does help you to predict
further out what's going to go on uh I
have a friend George Mack and he said
remote work is the best thing to happen
to Skilled people in developing worlds
and the worst thing to happen to
unskilled people in developed worlds so
if you were to think that you're going
to have all of these Indians that are
potentially online that have relatively
good levels of Education fast internet
access all this sort of stuff like how
will getting on to talking about States
and the way that they develop how will
Immigration ever deal with remote work
if somebody far away can put a VR
headset on and start working as a in
some jobs and manual labor job somewhere
with an autonomous robot
so so first of all in 2013 I actually
gave a talk that talked about this I'm
like you know with telepresence your
immigration policy becomes your firewall
it's like 10 years ago
Jesus Christ yes yeah yeah yeah right so
so because if and only if you can
introdite that remote connection can you
stop somebody from telepresently
animating a robot right
go ahead dude it's just it's funny it's
funny to think about the fact that of
you
considering the new challenges that are
going to be faced by anything which is
virtual and people are going to optimize
for a way to find a solution to this you
have an unbelievable uh motivation for
people and the other thing is that you
could uh spend in the equivalent of
pesos you know it's going to be
significantly more incentivized for
countries in the developed world to use
this developing Talent so it's
interesting because it also
like it's a it's a I think it's net good
but it also Cuts right and left in
complicated ways right on the one hand
you have in a sense far more potential
immigrants on their hand they also don't
have to pick up stakes and leave their
home country for a job anymore so the
cultural influence in some ways is less
and it's more unless of a burden on
um
infrastructure on utilities but more
economic competition because anybody can
do it right so it's like arguably it's
more perfect competition you know from
an economic standpoint right but what I
think happens so first of all there's
lots of lots of different pieces of this
just to decouple them
the first thing is you know what people
will often say and I actually you know
of course I have some compassion for
that unskilled worker in the quote
developed world but I don't even
actually use the term developed and
developing world anymore I I call them
the descending world in the ascending
world and the reason I do that is not
just a word game but like developed
World implies sort of a satisfied end of
History we're done it's over and
developing you're just kind of catching
up right but descending and ascending
World imply well first of all there's
places that can descend like San
Francisco descending world right La
descending World okay these are places
that have gotten far worse over the last
10 years despite or arguably because of
the billions of dollars right you know
San Francisco may be the single worst
managed city in the world it shows what
American politicians are capable of If
Only They had the budget which is to say
capable of just like basically
destroying you know civilization
um and foreign
[Laughter]
so you know but on the other side you
know and of course there are some I mean
Francis Suarez is an American politician
I think he's great he's able to draw
people into Miami right
but
um the you know so so on the one hand
like SF is descending world but on their
side of the world like you know places
in India places in Southeast Asia placed
in Nigeria placed in Brazil these these
guys are getting Sky hooks the internet
they're ascending world right you can
see the energy there right these folks
have that you know for the first time a
quality of opportunity because they have
the internet connection and they have
remote work and they can get paid in
cryptocurrency
um or with something like you know
transferwise or something like that
things are starting to get level you're
starting to have a globally Fair uniform
market right and so the thing about this
is
nationalism and capitalism and socialism
and internationalism like you know the
socialism and international those are
two different ways of kind of thinking
about the moral obligation and the
nationalism of capitalism are two
different ways to think about the
self-interest right and you can have
different combinations and what I think
you're going to so in the 20th century
is basically the Nationalist capitalist
versus the international socialist right
that was kind of what the early part of
the 20th century at least was right
um and arguably the middle
now I think it's the internationalist
capitalists and the national and
socialists the cloud and the land okay
why because
um so you know if you go back to 1950
and you talk about that
American factory worker who on a single
guy with a high school degree could
provide for you know their family and
have a house and so forth that's like
romanticized that's like this Halcyon
period in you know all kinds of stuff
like you know that was such a great time
blah blah during that time period of
course the rest of the world was bombed
out ruined right Japan had been
atomically nuked you know China's in the
middle of it's like just finishing this
communist First National Civil War India
I think it just gotten Independence
um and obviously it would be involved in
World War II Europe was totally bombed
out Soviet Union you know was bombed out
after you know giant war with Germany
like basically most of the world was
just absolutely in Ruins so America had
more relative power right it could get
by and all of those see the opposite of
the unskilled person in a you know
wealthy country is the skilled person in
a you know temp rarely unwealthy country
this person who's like really smart and
hardworking and frankly would beat this
other guy in a Fair competition was not
even in the game you know this Chinese
PhD physicist was just like executed by
Mao or something like that right and I'm
just saying PhD as an example let's say
a very talented person right
um
and so you know with having nothing
against this other person they had a
huge artificial boost up right and fine
they had a great decade maybe they had a
great Century in some ways okay but now
kind of the The Winds of time the chains
you know things are are shifting and you
know it this is basically where
nationalism versus internationalism the
moral case comes in right and you know
the nationalists will argue and and I
want to try to be fair to both points of
view right Nationals argue well don't we
have an obligation to somebody who's in
our own country and they're you know
someone who speaks our language and
waves our flag and pays our taxes and
serves in our military and so and so
forth you know how come you're you want
to give a job or work with this guy from
the other side of the world right and uh
then the capitalist will say well uh are
you gonna pay you know why should I give
a job to this less talented person over
here when there's a more talented
hard-working person over there who
doesn't have the same entitlement and
are you going to pay his salary no
you're not you want me to pay a salary
so you can feel good about you know the
nation or whatever you want me to
basically pay for your stuff right and
so both parties I think have a logical
argument where they're calling the other
guy a free writer
you see what I'm saying the nationalists
are saying the capitalist is free
writing on the country and so they
provided the capital is saying the
Nationalist is free riding on their
budget and the businesses they provided
right and uh you know I'm not sure I'm
actually trying to Faithfully represent
both views because I can I think I can
there is a tension there
and similarly like the Socialists and
Internationals will have a very similar
conversation but with a more inflected
kind of thing right the Socialists will
say because now they'll talk about the
state oh I can't believe you're
Outsourcing those jobs you're pushing
them overseas you're impoverishing our
people and so on and international will
say well our people are actually richer
and they've had a richer century and a
richer maybe like half Millennium
whereas these people are you know have
been underprivileged or whatever for a
long time and they're hard working so by
the doctrine of all people are equal
then we should give them a job first
right so again those are two like so
basically both the self-interest and the
moral stuff you can kind of line it up
which is our duty is to those people in
our community versus our duty is to
those people who've had it tough or you
know who you know are currently you know
weaker right uh and and are more
meritorious on some axis right
and uh you know because those are
internally consistent
that's why I see them becoming the land
in the cloud right that's like the
primary political axis of this century
is not right left but it is the land in
the cloud it is the National Socialist
and the internationalist capitalists
yeah that's interesting well I mean it's
one of the things we've been talking
about a lot on the show recently has
been declining Male Achievement and a
global sexual Marketplace and the fact
that it is higher rates of young people
are struggling to get together whether
that be for a short period of time or
even for a long period of time the
number of people under the age of 30
reporting No Sex in the last year has
tripled in the last 10 years so on and
so forth so if you are some guy in Idaho
who couldn't get a date and now can't
get a job because VR has made not only
the sexual Marketplace more opened up
but it's also made the job Marketplace
more opened up I would be interested to
see what sort of uh unrest Downstream
from that potentially happens
domestically
it's possible I mean the thing is also
though if it's low T it's a low
testosterone like are people gonna fight
that's going to domesticate everybody in
any case yeah I don't know right like
but you know what I what I think you
actually get is uh disorganized rather
than organized balance so when everybody
thinks about like War you know or they
think about the 20th century with like
uniform guys with tanks and planes like
that's like a super organized type of
thing you know and
I think something that is Upstream of
that is is implicit that people aren't
really thinking about and that is that
in the 20th century
everybody was accustomed to coming to a
factory taking orders from a foreman
and then all mapping out and you know
turning screws cranking wrenches Etc and
then like coming back right and that's
actually the same as sort of platoon
level combat it's actually the same as
football where you all huddle around the
quarterback take the orders go span out
boom do the similar to school
similar to school exactly right but that
is simply not how people uh operate
today in the west you're looking at a
screen and it's it's very much async and
it's like attached detached do something
information work come back right
so here's the thing that that factory
experience meant that all kinds of
things even Union organizing
leaned on the factory experience okay so
I have a thread on this basically let's
kind of you know my thesis is the
assembly line trained people for the
top-down Mass politics of the 1900s
and so because today's workplace is
network based with the crucial exception
of China any viable political political
ideology will scale up what people are
doing on their devices
okay so in the in the 1900s they were at
the assembly line today they're on their
phones and their computers
and so what that means is whether it's
politics whether it's Wars it will start
with the device
that's what it looks like right that's
actually you know whether it starts with
a meme whether it starts with hacking
somebody or it starts with yelling at
them online uh even if it's like a drone
or like a bomb dead like all that is
just device driven stuff right so it's
network not you know it's it's giant
networks hitting each other and like
stochastic as opposed to
huge wavefronts of like armored
uniformed tanks and planes and guys with
uniforms hitting each other so the real
world is becoming more virtual like
yeah exactly that's right and you know
the thing is that um you know this is
like our our models of What conflict
looks like are based on this you know
people think oh when there's a war it's
gonna look like the History Channel
thing you were mentioning earlier Hitler
vestalin on the you know bloodlet right
and so they think it's going to look
like that but it's actually going to
look like what we've seen over the last
20 years which is Terrorism social media
memes hacks
um cancellation de-platforming unbanking
assassination like that's What conflict
looks like in the network age and
there's both a good and a bad aspect to
it the good aspect is it's probably less
destructive of property and lives than
like nukes and stuff like that it's also
worse because like the Battlefront is
like everywhere and nowhere it's
decentralized right like how do you take
down or stop a thousand individual
groups of actors yeah exactly so it's
just it's something which is more like I
don't know the 30 Years War it just goes
on forever because there's a Battlefront
you know and it's not even declared it's
just like escalating hostility and um
that's actually what you know in the
book I talk about uh American anarchy
versus Chinese control and this is a
Sci-Fi scenario okay and it's possible
that you know these don't actually come
to pass in quite this way but
American Anarchy essentially you know my
premise there and you're talking about
the guy in Idaho in this kind of a piece
of that right uh
you know have you seen the political
compass yes the box right yeah so top
left communism top right fascism bottom
left uh I'd say wokeness bottom right
anarka capitalism or let's say maximals
okay so people are used to saying the
top left and the top right Loop into the
same thing that's called horseshoe
Theory right they say you know stalinism
and hitlerism basically there's this uh
this great movie uh called the Soviet
story okay which actually shows the
propaganda posters of the Communists and
the fascists and how similar they were
right and you actually already see this
today where you see Memes from one side
being copied and repurposed on the other
side so that was actually a conscious
thing because you know Hitler called his
group the Nationalist socialists right
the National Socialist German Workers
Party he stole a bunch of lines from the
left and vice versa Stalin stole
nationalism so and say became kind of
similar right so that's horseshoe Theory
and people think that's the only way
that the left and the right can overlap
is in this fascist total state or this
this really authoritarian totalitarian
total state which could be their
communist or fascists right orbital's
written about this everybody's warned
about this Etc so that's the thing that
everybody's immunized of they have that
image in their head okay but rather than
simply horseshoe Theory I propose figure
eight Theory where you take again that
political compass and now let's talk
about the lower left and lower right
quadrants
low left quadrant is wokeness it's
antifa you know all this stuff and lower
right is maximalism and arco-capitalism
Etc so like Ultra libertarian right
Ultra libertarian life so Ultra
libertarian left will say everybody's
equal
and the ultra libertarian right will say
you ain't the boss of me
and where do those add up to
but add will those add up to even though
they've got obvious differences they've
got a left and right component that
annihilates they've got a component that
sums and the component that sums is
against all forms of authority
right all authorities illegitimate all
hierarchy is illegitimate this order is
illegitimate you know burn it all down
right that's what everyone is equal and
you ain't the boss of me add up to is
the current order is illegitimate and so
despite their differences just like the
Communist Nazis obviously had real
differences they have real similarities
in terms of their degree of total
organization totalitarianism right
wokeness and maximalism have immense
differences but they are aligned on
basically being against the current
order you know whether they're calling
it institutionally racist or they're
calling it you know Klaus Schwab and the
great reset and you know you can argue
there's like aspects of both whatever or
you know you can take pieces of that
right and people most people aren't like
um
some folks are very ideological and they
will take X and not Y and so on but for
a lot of people
they they will kind of take both in this
weird compartmentalized way they'll like
agree with both right you know and uh
you know there'll be people who will nod
yeah it's racist and I hate the great
reset and so on do you know what I'm
saying and it's it's kind of like
something where
um that's what I mean there's a sum as
well as a cancellation of terms right so
if
communism and fascism leads to challenge
terrorism and tyranny the bottom left
and bottom right corner some to Anarchy
given the fact that you've been focused
on network States a lot recently and
your um
your current new adopted homeland of
choice has been Singapore what have you
looked at from Singapore what have you
learned in terms of effective ways to
build a state last few decades for that
country has been
amazing phenomenal yeah like yeah pretty
unprecedented so what did you learn or
what are the lessons that should have
been taken away from Singapore's
ascendancy well so I am splitting time
between Singapore and India
um and actually uh you know I'm trying
to spend a lot more time in India in
particular just because
um there's amazing like that's also like
the last five or ten years in India have
been phenomenal
um and I mean like on the ground you've
got the Starbucks you've got the
internet and so on and so forth but
um on your question on Singapore
um
I mean you know they had
Singapore is
I think an important model for this
Century you know because they had a CEO
founder
right which was Lee Kuan Yew who you
know was perhaps the single greatest
leader of the 20th century you know a
lot of the other guys you know who are
great leaders
um you know are wartime leaders they
killed a lot of people or they ordered
troops into battle and look there's a at
there's an aspect of humanity which is
we respect conquerors we respect winners
we respect that kind of thing right but
Lee Kuan Yew did not you know kill lots
of people it wasn't a communist dictator
it wasn't you know it wasn't a wartime
leader and so and so forth he just
leveled up a country right and you know
in some ways like one way I think about
it is there's sort of like four levels
of leadership you know if you ask
yourself
why does socialism keep arising over and
over again one way of answering that
question is it is the easiest way to
become a leader of men
why because in any functional Society
you can just start yelling that 51 is
oppressed by 49 percent
and that will always work like you can
find some access and just start
sandpapering that okay and you know a
conflict is attention and attention is
currency and you just if you're
Shameless you just level up and
basically socialism is like the lowest
skill way to put yourself at the head of
a mob it'll always work in almost every
country and the variance of this let's
call it demagoguery right we're pitting
some fraction versus the other then you
go one step up and you have nationalism
and nationalism is okay unify all of us
against these other guys on their side
of the Border you know like the English
versus the French or whatever you know
wogs begin at Calais or something I
think was the ancient you know saying or
whatever right no offense to French I'm
just quoting like the you know old you
know English guys so nationalism
the the good part about nationalism is
it stops the conflict internally people
are aligned internally they've got a
common cause
that's a good part the bad part is uh it
often starts worse you know because
people are so proud that it goes from
you know nationalism or patriotism into
jingoism or chauvinism or imperialism or
whatever right and again to all these
wars of people and then eventually they
get pushed back or whatever right okay
so then you go one level up from that
and now you get to capitalism and now
you're unifying people on the basis of a
common market cause and uh now defeating
the other guy doesn't mean killing them
or starting a war you're defeating them
in the market in a voluntary way where
they can submit and be acquired or would
have you you're virtualizing the
conflict and it's also positive sum
you're creating something of value but
you can lead a very large group like
Jeff Bezos leads like a million people
the scale of capitalistic Enterprises
can be very very large right and I don't
think actually we've seen the limits of
them yet
and then like the highest level I'd say
is to be a technologist leader where
you're like a lawn and you're I'm asking
all these people and it's not just
positive some you're not just building
something non-violently it's not so
something in the market you're literally
moving Humanity forward by you're not
just building an organization that ships
chairs for example which are valuable in
the market but that's building
spacecraft that doing something that's
never been done before so the level of
difficulty as a leader there is the
highest right should go from demagogue
to nationalist to capitalist to
technologists and like the degree of
difficulty of being a leader of men of
you know taking these folks this Capital
these resources putting them together
and doing something
gets harder but more valuable to society
in the medium to long run because you're
actually shipping something that pushes
all of humanity forward then of course
every other group can benefit from the
technologist doing that than they take
for granted you know 30 years later the
planes work the trains work that you
know they take all that stuff for
granted that that small group pushed
that forward and scaled it
but it was a small group that did that
right and so from that sort of ranking
of leaders right
um then like lky is like capitalist
Technologies he's basically like kind of
there right somewhere in between
um but very very high perhaps when the
best of the 20th century press the best
of the 20th century because
um you know what he did for Singapore he
pushed them forward he did innovate
actually on several things like you know
with Sovereign funds with how he you
know he micro optimized things like the
approach from the airport
do you know that no he really cared
about the fact that visiting dignitaries
when they hit Singapore that they would
drive through and they'd see everything
was clean and spotless they'd be like
wow okay
this is the spot in Asia for us to build
our HQ he understood we would call it
the importance of user interface
okay you have a clean user interface and
it signals something
about the site right why is it that you
want like a clean ux it's like okay they
polished it right and uh so that means
like lots of things are correct about it
um and uh so he understood that that
basically the guys were coming in to put
Capital into the country expected it to
be a quote third world basket case and
they would be surprised to the upside
and so he would like drive back and
forth in that route and be like put a
tree there put a tree there that needs
to go away this should not be done at
this time and so on and so forth right
and that's just like one thing but you
know he set up Singapore Airlines he did
all kinds of stuff he was basically the
CEO of the country you know and um
the thing about that is what I what I
talk about in the network state is
something where it takes aspects of at
least four different countries more than
that but it takes aspects of America
India Israel and Singapore right so part
of takes from Singapore is the concept
of a CEO founder of a country right
where it takes from America is you know
almost too many to enumerate but the
concept of like our Constitution and of
uh like an immigrant like people you
know like a like a nation of immigrants
but a nation of immigrants Emi
g-r-e-n-t-s
um what it takes from Israel is the
concept of a country founded by a book
theater herzl wrote a book called The
Jewish state in the late 1800s right
around the turn of the century proposing
um that the Jewish people have that they
were they were a nation without a state
a stateless nation proposing that they
have their own country and people
thought he's totally crazy and they
built towards it and 50 years later
Israel actually you know happened now
that gets us the fourth thing which is
India has non-violent Independence right
and so uh let's say with Gandhi you had
the non-violent Independence right so
you take those four things right you
have you know like uh America's
Constitution and all their contributions
you have Singapore's concept of the
city-state run by a Founder CEO
um you have the concept of nation
started with a book with a strong moral
cause right and you have the concept of
a Nation started non-violently that
managed to bind together folks of lots
of different ethnicities like both India
and the US have done right and actually
all four of those are really
multi-ethnic States right Israel has
Jews from around the world Singapore has
four different ethnicities India and
America have millions and millions of
people from all around
um I mean India is like Europe by the
way it's like North and South India are
like Finland and and Spain or something
they're as different as that but they're
all in one giant Union right
so so those also they have something
else you know what's in common among
those four countries
they're all Forks of the UK code base
right because like the American Fork is
like what if we took all Europeans and
you know most most Americans are no
longer of Anglo dissent but the UK code
base you know became the Constitution
and so on and Israel used to be a
British colony and Singapore used to be
British colony in India used to be a
British colony
the the Brits that we got it right is
that is that the lesson to take away
from this I I definitely respect the
British people I mean like the thing is
you know one way to actually talk about
the network state is when we can talk
about it but
people will so if you think about
America India Israel and Singapore
they're not anti-british or pro-british
they're post-british
right so let's say on a daily basis
people are not scoring every event as
whether they're for or against the
British but that's actually freed them
to build their own societies and then
over time like you know India doesn't
hate Britain anymore right like America
doesn't like everybody you know
take a lorry to the lou you know like
you guys
look Lads like you know whatever you
guys have contributed so much to
humanity that you know I of course
respected you've got Newton I mean
whatever you can't we could we could do
the entire
thing on just England and or really more
the UK's contributions to humanity and
it's funny I was saying England for a
second because the American way of doing
it often equates England with the UK but
of course in England it's like people
Irish will be very unhappy yeah you
start to do that yeah exactly that's
right so
the UK's contribution to the world is
you know dramatic and Aaron will always
say oh imperialism and so on and I grant
certainly like you know I'm glad India's
independent America's independent et
cetera but there are a lot of Empires
that were much worse you know if you
look at Timberland or something like
that you know they're a lot of folks
just put everybody to the sword and
whatnot relatively speaking you know
relative to most other you know giant
Empires I think the British you know
were if you're going to be imperialized
okay
um
should not say one wants to be but now
that we've got some distance and the
fullness of time and so on I respect Ren
from a distance so I do not want to be
imperialized by the Brits right and and
that's something where you know you know
it's I think it's I think that's a
reasonable point of view right and you
can have a firm handshake and do a deal
and and respect each other as equals and
Commercial partners and and so on right
um
anyway my point is in in the same way
that these societies evolved to be
post-british right I think a useful way
of thinking about it especially if the
U.S descends into what I call American
Anarchy is to be neither quote certainly
not anti-American but not also quote
reflexively pro-american but
post-american
right meaning like people will be
there'll be a huge attempt to pull
everybody into the endless American
Civil War okay but
if I ask you it this way whose side are
you on in hoodoo versus Tootsie or Sunni
versus Shiite right how about like
Protestant versus Catholic right answer
I'm not really on either side you know
in fact I kind of want to stay out of
the war zone and uh you know I hope they
come to peace and certainly at various
points in history you've had these folks
fight and you know but when you take
some distance from it I don't want to be
involved in that conflict
um and I actually think in retrospect
people will find the conflicts over
stupid things uh and tribal things that
are not you know the greatest good for
the greatest number right the you know
but
I also recognize there's sometimes an
arrow of history and you can't just be
naive and be like hey guys work it out
or whatever and you'll just get bullets
flying at you from from both sides right
so you know my my premise is that um
I think it's quite likely not a hundred
percent but I think it's quite likely
that uh neither blue team nor red team
in the US has the strength to totally
control events and both can be a spoiler
for the other that's one of the things
we've learned over the last year or so
and uh they're both heavily armed and
it's America's like more guns than
people or what have you right and uh you
know the
um
the the critical thing also is there's
Mutual disrespect right neither part
neither group wants to defer to the
other that's a big change you know there
isn't common ground or whatever these
are all things millions of people have
written about this I think where I
perhaps differ is I don't think there's
going to be any you know like easy
reconciliation I also think that the
um the manner in which it happens will
not exactly be blue versus red I think
it's quite possible it's green versus
orange did we talk about this no is this
spiral Dynamics
no it's uh at least not to my knowledge
it's about it basically uh there's
actually here's an animation that you
can put on there that will
um oh okay can you explain for the
people that are just listening can you
explain what I'm looking at sure so this
is showing a projected transformation of
the US
political
um you know Compass or or kind of
political landscape from the traditional
left-right Alliance of democrat
Republican into dollar green versus
Bitcoin orange or really centralization
versus decentralization and what you're
seeing is basically the top two
quadrants
are actually becoming the same thing and
essentially American statism and the
bottom two quadrants are going towards
you know Bitcoin maximalism and or
cryptocurrency and or decentralization
and so you can call the top is the land
and the you know the bottom there is a
cloud the top are the nationalists and
socialists at the bottom are the
internationalists and capitalists the
top is the centralized State the bottom
is a decentralized network and the top
is green and the bottom is orange and
the big thing about this is a good chunk
of the like sort of you know military
police state type of people you
traditionally think of as the right will
go with the dollar and a good fraction
of the internationalists the left
Libertarians Glenn Greenwald types et
cetera will go with Bitcoin right Jack
Dorsey claim green will go to bitcoin so
you'll see a lot of folks on blue and
red actually switch sides and that's a
different Coalition it may only be
um I don't know 20 or 30 percent that
switches sides but it's enough for it to
feel like a new thing right because
Dorsey Greenwald the sub stack
journalists and so on a bunch of
Intelligentsia go to big coin orange and
a bunch of the security State goes to
Dollar green and why do I say that these
are the two sides because
um
I mean if you think about the US
establishment right now
what are they doing there are printing
trillions of dollars passing these 100
like I don't even know how many 100
billion dollar bills there are right
this act that blah blah I won't even
name them they're so dumb
um they're starting simultaneous fights
with uh Tech Trump China Russia and also
to a lesser extent like Israel India
Hungary Brazil some extent Britain over
brexit some sent France over some
macron's comments
um and uh you know like
and their Ambitions in some ways are
going through the ceiling right fighting
proxy wars with multiple nuclear powers
and like a cold civil war with half
their own population and fighting all
The Tech Guys and fighting web 3 and BTC
and yelling at like everybody's even
slightly out of line like hungry or
whatever right
um and fighting them all at the same
time
right with an ideology of uh you know
what we call it wokeness or what have
you that
says that Merit doesn't exist
so they're not even taking the best
Americans anymore for the government
like they were you know under Clinton or
Obama you actually had a fair number of
smart people going into the government
but now that's a liability
um because you know let's say you're in
Tech you've had a successful cure they
won't even let you into the government
now because they they you know they want
to crack down on it that looks like
conflict of interest Etc right so lots
of folks with skills are not being
allowed in and
um
so you have to ask right like you sum
all of that up and
um this is why you're seeing you know
whether it's China whether it's Trump
whether it's Russia whether it's India
like people don't respect the US
establishment anymore and without
deference
you don't have
um you know like you have at a minimum
disregard where people push the envelope
and so on and so lack of deference me
and soft power isn't there so when
software isn't there the estashion is
trying to use hard power
but hard power means even more
disrespect you know unless you're unless
you're at the point that you're like uh
you know able to Atomic Bomb somebody
into submission like the the US did to
the Japanese or you know invade them and
denotify them like the Germans hard
power to the absolute limit you can
eventually regain soft power and so on
and so forth right
I don't feel that's necessarily going to
come about
the wild card is what I call Digital
hard power
okay and so the one thing that the U.S
establishment has in its back pocket and
I talk about this is basically I was
thinking about how to think about
digital power and uh you know just kind
of make this comments from a few months
ago I was like
digital power it's not really soft power
right meaning being de-platformed seeing
all your money Frozen that's much more
than just influence okay but it's also
not traditional hard power because
invisible it's intangible you can use it
against 100 million people and no one
sees it there's no bruises no explosions
right so what is it and the way I was
thinking about is actually it's like you
can cut the thing in two so four part
classification analog soft power analog
hard power digital soft power Digital
hard power right analog soft power
that's culture and influence analog hard
power that's bombs and bullets digital
soft power that's ranking recommendation
okay digital hardpower that's deep
platforming freezing seizing and the
difference is soft power is
probabilistic and hard power is
deterministic
okay so once you kind of cut it that way
and parse it that way that's like a
useful way of just kind of making this
make sense
analog soft power digital soft Powers so
culture and influence are like ranking
and recommendation you're just kind of
putting a thumb on the scales right
bombs bullets de plattering freezing
seizing I am not asking anymore right
you're just you know that Bernie Sanders
meme do you know what I'm saying yeah I
am no longer asking right okay so
they're just freezing they're just
seizing they're just freezing your
account you're an unperson or whatever
right and so the the big wild card like
you know the thing I disagree very much
with like Peter zihan for example is
he puts a lot of weight on like
America's aircraft carriers and its
nukes and other stuff geopolitics blah
blah and the thing is that yeah okay is
it true that that matters to some extent
yes but it matters less than it ever has
why because
um you have this entire new Cloud world
where so much stuff is happening first
and then it's getting printed out into
the physical world if at all okay and so
the you know for example with Ukraine
all the bombs and bullets are Downstream
of this huge Cloud campaign that Ukraine
ran to recruit the rest of the world
into it and sympathize with it right
where if it had not done that if had not
done this PR no one would care about it
right zielinski to you know at least
from a leaving aside all the other stuff
from just a military PR strategy thing
he went and gave addresses to all these
different parliaments to kind of bring
them into he was constantly like
recruiting from the outside using the
network right expanding it beyond the
borders of Ukraine to this giant digital
kind of thing right and uh and that's
how he got the physical resources they
were printed out from the digital thing
that was up in the sky he printed out
those resources and brought them in to
Ukraine okay
um there's lots of other things that are
that are kind of like that but
point being that
um insofar as the U.S establishment
manages to hang on if you look at things
like I don't know you know what the F-35
is
the fighter jet yeah so if you look at
stuff like the F-35 the Zumwalt the
literal combat ship the Ford class
carrier like I mean these are just
gigantic
like multi-billion Dollar in some cases
multi-trillion dollar catastrophes right
it's the same US Government that's like
spending 300 million dollars on a bus
land they're wasting billions of dollars
on this military stuff and people are
just they you know like
they're just like yeah I know but we
waste lots of money and lots of stuff it
doesn't matter whatever but it's
you just can't blow like a trillion a TR
you know just like that money starts to
add up especially if like for example
the Chinese play an asymmetric physical
game you know they're smart they're like
the world leaders in drones and other
stuff their Doctrine says yeah America
sends these aircraft carriers we'll send
drones and blow them up asymmetrically
and the entire you know F-35 is like a
manned you know like like airplane even
Top Gun like this recent movie has some
line on it which is like where the last
manned aircraft why are you doing manned
aircraft now like it's it's literally
like
having you know Cavalry in World War one
is just going to get cut to Ribbons by
machine guns obviously right so this
entire physical military build out is I
don't quite say it's obsolete that's not
exactly right but a lot of it's based on
premises that are no longer you know in
effect it's not necessarily it might
might need to get defeated by a startup
military by a military that does not
have such assumptions for people to
reevaluate it because it's just like a
corporation where you have divisions
that Define themselves by being like man
fighter pilots or like we're the guys in
the tanks we don't want guys in the
tanks you want to remote control the
tanks you don't want the humans in there
but they are like oh it's Brave or
whatever right anyway like I look I I'm
certainly not
um
there's folks who know more about the
military for sure than I do but
everything I've dug into on this with
like you know this book called uh the
kill chain
um
it's not a book called 2034 we should
talk about this and those are guys who
have either seen military budgets and
approved them or they've actually been
Marines or you know this guy was like
the chief of staff of I don't just have
um gosh Supreme Allied Commander right
okay so so you have folks who are you
know if you read the kill chain and
there's two different books by the way
called The Kill chain I'm talking about
the one by Christian Bros okay if you
read those or read 2034 you'll see that
folks who are inside the military are
saying uh you know there's actually a
lot of issues here so I am not very
confident on America's Hard power in a
serious fight with China in its own
backyard because like you know America
is just overconfident they have not
faced a peer competitor in a long time
they don't care as much as China does
China's backyard China makes all the
physical stuff America has trillion
dollar you know like overruns and this
on all this equipment
um I mean China cares about Taiwan and
it's right there and America has to
project power from the other side of the
world and who's going to win a war of
attrition the guy who can like wheel up
bombs and tanks and so on right there or
the one who has to bust it in from their
side of the world and who speaks a
language and has a you know like people
have just been inculcated since birth to
care about this versus a TV War you know
all of these other wars in the Middle
East America has fought
have basically been things where people
can switch to channel they don't have a
personal cost now that Ukraine is
actually having a gas cost you know it's
not it's not bombs and bolts it's not
genuine human lives you know like people
don't want to fight anymore and the last
thing I would just say is basically on
this with kovid uh you know
immediately it got polarized politically
and so with any war with China
immediately 50 of the US will be against
it depending on who's in power or
whatever and just with covid it could
flip it could flip multiple times the
left is for the rise against the rise
for it the left is against it whatever
right so I am like extremely bearish on
American hard power and like a serious
serious fight and we'll also see with
the Ukraine stuff you know we'll see but
the the immediate surge by the way of
like American anything is insane it like
goes completely vertical this is the
current thing concept you know what I'm
talking about yes yeah so if you go to
Google Trends and you go and you type in
like BLM or Ukraine or something you'll
see a very common thing which is it goes
totally vertical to like 100 everybody
in the world cares about this and then
it's like a ski slope drop off and it
looks just like a coin pump and dump
okay in fact it's actually arguably
similar for everybody is gaining status
or whatever by talking about this thing
and then uh nobody cares right like and
so if you can somehow withstand that
insane level of peak intensity which
it's like a tsunami by the way it's like
an information tsunami everybody in the
world suddenly cares they've just like
gone it's like bipolar right like people
like a bipolar World entire world just
goes absolutely manic off the charts
caring about this thing that they didn't
even care about two weeks ago it's life
and death to them they're willing to go
and kill and die for it or burn things
down and then three examples they don't
care at all again
okay and they will never care about it
again but the thing is already burned
down or it's blown up whatever if you
can somehow design something that can
withstand that Peak intense which is
hard by the way it's like you know what
a tsunami wall is yes right in Japan
these giant walls that because the
tsunamis Peak energy it's like a super
tall thing if you can design it so it's
taller than the peak you can maybe push
it back right if you can design walls to
keep out that information tsunami
somehow this gets the information diet
then you can resist the current thing
and if you can resist the current thing
you'll probably win
because like you know in Afghanistan
with the Taliban like their lesson was
uh like fight 20-year insurgencies
you know something like this is
apocryphal but it's like oh you
Americans may have the clocks but we
have the time
meaning they could just
cry they're not going anywhere right and
eventually like here's where Afghanistan
is and here's where they live and here's
where America is on the other side of
the world and eventually they'll get
tired and they're gonna go home right
and that's probably the logic of Ukraine
and Taiwan which is Russia cannot give
up on Ukraine and China cannot give up
on Taiwan they're right there
and so America can eventually give up
and America probably will eventually
give up right that's like you know now
what will happen in a year or five years
or ten I don't know but it will probably
eventually go up just like it's given up
on Afghanistan and other things people
just get tired and you know the global
war on terror movie by the way that was
playing effectively in the 2000s which
dominated everything for like 10 years
just went off the headlines and in the
2010s was replaced by like woken Trump
right it's not like there was some I
mean I guess you could say you know
Osama Bin Laden being killed this Grand
Finale or something like that but it
really was something that went down like
this it wasn't like an official changing
of the channel there wasn't like a wrap
up it wasn't like you know well we did X
Y and Z right and there's no post-mortem
the troops are actually still there in
some places there's still bombs flying
and so it's like just a mess that was
left after it there's no cleanup or
anything but they just changed the
channel right and I think what happens
is
we'll see it's possible that there's
some like crazy acting out on the
international stage for a while but I
think it's quite possible to just change
the channel to like just this gigantic
domestic free-for-all maybe in 2024.
um and uh and then I don't know I don't
know what happens but I do think we
should prepare for a post-american Age
and what that means is we haven't had
like you know people say oh America had
a civil war and so before you haven't
had Civil War or civil conflict or
serious conflict in a place that it's
like the Hub of the world
you know you didn't have in Civil War in
1860s it was something where it
interrupted trade like the flow of
cotton and stuff like that that was
interrupted but it wasn't like oh this
is the Sea of the UN and this is the
reserve currency of the world and this
is where Google is and this is where you
know like all like you didn't have the
Hub blowing apart
right and even when the Soviet Union
fell all these countries that folded
into the Soviet Union
they could at least now fold into the
U.S there's a new Big Daddy right and a
few of them like North Korea and Cuba
they kept the Communist banners up or
whatever and they've just kind of been
like these Frozen things moving in time
but most other countries they just
stopped playing all the Communist music
once the funding from the Soviet Union
went out and they flipped over to the
capital side basically right
I'm not saying this 100 and as I said
the digital soft power Digital hard
power may keep the US afloat for longer
than we think that's a card that has yet
to be played you know freezing people
out of their Google accounts tracking
them with all the Apple stuff there's
some really terrifying things that a
small group of people could do if
they're really pushed against the wall
and if the state essentially either
takes over and or fuses with the tech
companies that's what this antitrust
stuff is like the resolution of it is
effectively nationalization of big Tech
by the US government no matter what else
the justification is even if it's an
economic justification at the end of the
day FBI CIA and it's able to get all the
back doors they were denied 10 years ago
well part of me hopes that the uh
crystal ball Cassandra truth saying
ability that you seem to have a track
record of might be a little bit less
accurate with this one look but Audrey
let's let's bring this one home brother
let's bring it home okay so so
essentially
um that scenario for either American
Anarchy or uh which is a conflict
between these groups the green and
orange or kind of American tech
companies having this digital control
over people and conversely in China I
see if American Anarchy the opposite of
American Anarchy is Chinese control so
you are being Iris scanned everywhere
you have drones overhead you have the
digital Yuan tracking every purchase and
China's uh argument here will be this is
what's necessary to maintain stability
do you want American Anarchy and
America's argument will be this at least
we're free do you want Chinese control
right so because I don't I don't
actually think like China will invade
the us or something it's like this
heavily armed porcupine of you know no
one will want a piece of that it's just
all these people like shooting each
other bombing each other crazy things
happening there just escalating okay BLM
and Jan 6 all the time is kind of one
possible model of what that becomes
whether that's by 2024 2028 or 2032 I
don't know but there's a graph a visual
capitalist which just shows the chaos
escalating right it's like civil unrest
to get Quantified it's just been
increasing since the 2000s right
and it's got It's got like remission and
then it comes back it's like crypto it
kind of has this crypto went crypto
summer and crypto winter and crypto
summer but it's on the way up just like
political summer the heat keeps coming
okay so between American Anarchy and
Chinese control those are not great
choices and China will also to many
countries basically say guess what we've
got a whole surveillance stack it's
TurnKey unless you want your country to
fall into Civil War and mimic America
just hit sign right here sign your life
over to China we'll install the
surveillance date and you'll never have
unrest right many countries will take
that but of course it's a fascian
bargain because people are tracked you
know but people will unfortunately
I I mean but in two choices between that
which which is basically you know like
AR-15s shooting each other all the time
versus being Irish skin a lot of people
will take the Chinese control option
unfortunately and uh so that's how
China's soft power just expands all it's
Belton Road 2.0 and so on they'll just
put a clamp on their own society and
then export it they're already doing
this
and so against that we need a better
alternative right we have something
which is
um for the other 80 of the world it's
neither American nor Chinese and in fact
for the 50 of Chinese and probably close
to 50 of Americans that don't want a
piece of either of these things right
like a good people forget like lots of
Chinese people are effectively Chinese
liberals they're internationalist
capitalists they want peace they want
trade these are the folks I mean look
before 2016 like the US and China were
like the motors of the world even as
late as 2019 Obama was a multilateral
internationalist Democrat that made a
movie called he made a movie called
American Factory by like Chinese people
and Americans working in concert to
build things right just as America's
kind of lost its mind over the last
eight years China's also gone Ultra
nationalists Xi Jinping has replaced all
these Governors you know this is
something that's not as reported in the
US but something like you know 90 of
Governors and people in the standing
committee and so on have all been
replaced as of 2017 were like Ultra
nationalists so it has gone as far far
to the Nationalist right in some ways as
America has gone woke okay so they're
all crazy in their own way they've got
this anti-japan other sentiments boiling
on their own internet right so between
those two things what if the choice is
neither what if the choices uh just in
like as in the uh the Cold War there's
the first world the second world the
third world the non-aligned movement but
these guys came in third what if this
time it's not the third rule but it's
web three what if it's not the nylon
movement but it's the Align movement
what if it doesn't come in last but it
comes in first
right where all the other peace loving
peoples of the world
are able to effectively align behind
crypto protocols which give genuine rule
of law okay meaning you've got freedom
of speech freedom of contract uh you
have uh contracts that work across
borders you know you're not going to be
cheated you have international
reputation you have something that's the
equivalent of Harvard but it's on chain
because your crypto credentials are
there but it doesn't have fees it's not
exclusive in the same way but it's more
meritocratic many of these institutions
um you know for example with media I've
talked about this like uh you know
having if you look at my talk on The
Ledger of record that talks about
actually putting media on chain you look
at my talk on crypto credentials it
talks about putting colleges on chain
obviously people have talked about
putting the Federal Reserve on chain
um
and and Wall Street on chains you take
these American institutions and you
build more fair on-chain versions and
you prepare for like the US Hub to maybe
just like explode into Sparks or not be
there for us right and that is not
anti-American in fact you know it's you
wish the best for these folks and in
fact you want to help a lot of Americans
that want something that's Centrist it's
post-american where it just doesn't rely
on something that could go down in a
burst of flame right and it's
constructive and it can be done without
trying to get everybody to buy in you
just build these systems online right so
one piece of it is web3 systems and the
other piece of it is if you go to the
networkstate.com you can read that about
how it's not simply about building the
Technologies also about building the
community and the societies and I won't
be able to recapitulate the whole thing
but go to the networkstate.com and if
you're interested in what the
alternative is to American Anarchy and
Chinese control it might be startup
societies and network States and you can
read more there I very much appreciate
the fact that the book is online it's
updatable you're continuing to evolve
all of the different elements as you go
through it there's a a one-pager
a thousand word a single essay and a
single line I think that explains
everything that's going on dude look
this is very very interesting I very
much appreciate the way that you think I
love the idea that everything seems to
be a little bit orthogonal and then it's
a a new way to introduce ideas uh what
else should people do if they like what
they've heard today where else should
they go to keep up to date with the
stuff you're doing
um well you can go to the network
city.com subscribe and you can just get
notified when the V2 of the book comes
out and I'm also at twitter.com front
slash Bala GS which is
b-a-l-a-g-i-s and it's all free so let
me know what you think dude I appreciate
you thank you for the day thank you
what's happening people thank you very
much for tuning in if you enjoyed that
episode then press here for a selection
of the best clips from the podcast over
the last few weeks and don't forget to
subscribe
peace
[Music]